A little over a week ago I made a video titled
25 Things You Missed In The Stephen King's
IT Trailer.
Here's a link if you missed it.
And in that video I asked you guys to offer
up your input in the comments and I got an
amazing response.
You all had a lot of insightful thoughts about
the trailer and things I didn't catch in my
initial video.
I've also been rereading the book, and it's
been making me appreciate the finer details
of the trailer even more.
I read through all the comments on that video,
which, at the time of writing, there are over
1,000, so HUGE thank you for all the support
on that one; and I picked out some favorites
to talk about in this video.
Now a lot of you had interesting ideas about
the meaning behind all the astronomy references,
and I'm going to save those theories for the
end of this video because they may go into
spoiler territory, at least for the book,
but don't worry, I'll give you a spoiler alert
before we get there.
Here are 12 Things I Missed In The Stephen
King's IT Trailer.
The biggest thing I missed in my initial video
was the setting.
This upcoming film actually takes place in
the 80s.
Apologies for that misinformation on my part
and thank you to each and every one of you
that pointed this out in the comments -- all
2 billion of you, thank you for pointing out
that this movie takes place in the 80s.
A couple of you let me know that more specifically,
the film takes place in 1989 and this is backed
up by the technology you see in the trailer,
and the fact that you can just look it up
online.
It takes place in the 80s.
But what's more interesting to me is why the
filmmakers have chosen the 80s for this film.
Many of you confirmed my suspicion that the
book will be split into two movies, meaning
that the second movie will take place in 2016,
the same year that Part 1 was in production.
When you consider the fact that the first
movie is technically a flashback, that kind
of makes this whole reboot series a modern
day remake of IT, an interesting choice when
you consider the significance of creepy clowns
in our culture today, such as the Staten Island
clown and his many copycats over the last
few years.
We'll see if that plays into the second film
at all.
I'll never forget that scene in the adult
portion of the mini-series where Ben notices
Pennywise on the side of the road; something
that seemed to happen quite a lot in October
2016.
This is our next item.
The film is scheduled to release September
8, 2017.
You might be wondering, "CZ, how did you miss
this?
It says it right there!"
Well, it's not the release date that I missed,
but rather, the significance behind it.
In the story, IT returns to the town every
27 years to terrorize Derry.
Commenter CynicalCatLady points out, "the
first screen adaptation of IT was first aired
in 1990, and twenty-seven years later, the
infamous dancing clown is re-emerging to breathe
fresh terror into a new generation, just as
he does in the novel."
To me, that's so cool.
That's perfect timing for a new movie, I love
when movies take real time into account.
In my video, I mention how Pennywise's eyes
don't show up in the reflection.
Some of you mentioned that this could just
be because the eyes are enhanced in visual
effects and they just didn't want to do the
effect in the reflection as well.
That is something that crossed my mind, having
done quite a bit of visual effects myself,
but then I saw this comment, which doesn't
make any sense, but it got me thinking about
the novel, and how IT doesn't have a shadow.
So maybe no eyes in the reflection is the
film manifestation of that, or at the very
least, one of those choices that's easy to
make because you know it's going to save you
a lot of money in visual effects.
Oftentimes the reasoning for a choice made
in a film is something simple like that.
For example, I questioned what that key might
be around Beverly's neck.
A commenter named WhenTheSkyTurnsDark points
out that it may just be her house key, which
she needs to keep with her because, unlike
many of the others, she might not have someone
at home who can let her in all the time.
We already know her Dad is unreliable, and
she may use the necklace for the key because
her Dad would beat her if she ever lost it.
Here's another thing I got wrong.
I pointed out these flower beds in the wide
shot and said they were arrows.
Many of you took a closer look and discovered
that they are actually crosses.
While we are on this landscape shot, I have
to admire the choice of location.
This is a town called Port Hope in Ontario,
Canada, one of three Canadian cities where
the movie was filmed.
You can see much more clearly here that they
are indeed crosses, and as a couple of you
speculated, that that's because of the church
right across the street.
The park over here is called Memorial Park,
and I'm sure there are plenty of Memorial
Parks across North America, but that is also
the name of an often mentioned location in
Derry in the book.
It's more of a coincidence than anything that
would be super important to the movie, but
I found it interesting nonetheless.
Another useless but interesting location I
noticed was right across the street from Memorial
Park, there's a restaurant called Turtle John's.
There are constant references to "The Turtle"
the novel, and I'll actually discuss that
in more detail a bit later on in the video.
There's also this canal, which will play the
part of the offshoot of the Kenduskeag Stream
that runs through Derry.
Not only is that where Ben first meets Pennywise
in the book, but I was checking out some photos
of the canal and it's shallow enough to wade
in, so I wouldn't be surprised if this also
the location for The Barrens, which if you
aren't familiar with IT, is the place where
the group basically bonds and becomes friends
when they get in trouble for building a dam
downstream.
Again, it's not like a dealbreaker for the
movie, but it's just a nice touch to see when
locations are actually connected in a film,
especially one that focuses so much on the
town it's located in and has scenes that move
from location to location.
There's also a library right in the center
of town here, which brings me to the next
thing I missed.
So in the mini-series, Richie has his confrontation
with Pennywise in the library, which is obviously
an iconic scene.
In the novel however, it's Ben who spends
all of his time at the library, especially
before he becomes friends with the other 6
kids.
He is at the library on the last day of school,
which is what it would seem they are depicting
here.
For the record, in the book, he's also the
one who goes back to the library as an adult,
seeing as how it was like his safe haven from
the bullies as a child.
This flooded basement scene in the trailer
sparked some debate in the comments as to
whose basement it was.
I naturally thought it was the Denborough
basement just because Bill is down there by
himself, when he encounters the illusion of
Georgie.
Some people suggested it could be the 29 Neibolt
basement.
I don't think that's too likely considering
the modern appliances seen here, and this
guy TaylorTV brings up another good point,
which is that it would make sense that he
encounters Georgie in the cellar, because
in the first chapter, Bill sends him down
there to get the turtle wax, which we'll get
back to, essentially sending him to his own
doom in a way.
So IT takes advantage of this by using Georgie's
image in the basement to guilt his brother.
Seems like a logical way of looking at it.
OK, so before I get into the astronomy stuff,
there were a few things that people brought
up, that were not things that I missed, but
things that I didn't really think anyone would
miss, so I'll just list those off real quick.
This could be the Leper that Eddie sees at
29 Neibolt.
This could be a depiction of the Black Spot
fire.
It also might be a replacement for the junkyard
bird scene.
I actually wouldn't really mind if it was.
Bill doesn't stutter at all in the trailer,
but I'm not too worried about that, I feel
like the trailer was just cut with good audio
from him to make it flow better.
OK with that out of the way, this next part
is going to contain some spoilers for the
book regarding the origin of IT, so if you
don't want hear, I'll see you in the next
video.
Assuming we both survive....
OK.
So You guys have been telling me that you
think the astronomy stuff is a reference to
the fact that IT came to Earth from outer
space.
This ties into the whole subplot about how
IT is basically the Stephen King demon, and
how the counterbalance is The Turtle, which
is like the creator of all things.
I'm not going to dig too deep into the lore
for the sake of simplicity, but basically
what you need to know is that both IT and
The Turtle come from this void in outer space.
Looking at the trailer with that information,
I started to notice even more references to
outer space scattered throughout Derry.
There were some people in the comments who
were not buying into this because of the fact
that in the first scene with the Denborough
brothers, Bill seems to sealed Georgie's boat
with Gulf Wax, as opposed to the Turtle Wax
that Georgie fetches from the cellar in the
book.
So their argument is that the filmmakers only
really have a reason to do this if they are
not going to feature the turtle and the ritual
and stuff.
I don't think this will be the case.
The ending of the TV mini-series is widely
considered it's weakest point, and it doesn't
include the ritual.
Also, with this movie taking place in a different
decade, it stands to reason that different
products would be more relevant in another
time period.
And with the new time period comes a new audience
and new fans.
So if you're an IT fan, new or old, be sure
to drop me a like on this video.
If you're new to the channel, my name is CZ
and I am actually the greatest director of
all time.
I know a lot of people are going to get triggered
by me saying that, but even Obama himself
has agreed, so if you're into the scary stuff,
then remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, yes, we're making
the jump to weekly content.
I was planning on making the shift later this
year, but you guys are killing it with all
the support right now, you're just killing
it like John Wayne Gacy out there, so I'm
going to try to push out the weekly content
a little bit early, but don't be mad if I
miss a week in the early going here.
Make sure you ring that death-bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.